welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 24 and we're gonna learn how you can
become a better marketer how aside from
making great products how do you get
people excited about Tesla there's a lot
of people I know and that I talked to
who are just intrigued and interested
and excited about Tesla as a company the
thing that really focus on at Tesla is
like really put all the money into an
attention into trying to make the
product as compelling as possible so
because I think that the really the way
to sell any product is through
word-of-mouth so if the one somebody
gets the car they really like it they
and actually the key is like to have a
product that people love and and journal
people that if they're a party or toward
friends whatever you'll talk about the
things that you love but if you just
like something it's okay you're not
gonna care that much but if you feel the
reactions from the highs and the lows
really I'm gonna it's you're gonna talk
you know and and then that'll Jerry's
word-of-mouth and that's basically how
our sales have grown like we don't we're
not spend any money on advertising or
endorsements or and so any more like
fives our car they just water because
they they like the car and you know it's
like it's genuine when you look at the
big picture there's three things an
entrepreneur must learn number one is PR
and what you're talking about is PR the
other the other day Fox News interviewed
me to find out if I would endorse my
friend Donald Trump for president you
know much that's worth you know they
they call branded us
Kiyosaki reg dad and Trump yeah that's
incredibly priceless you know so getting
PR is a number one skill under that is
marketing and marketing does is like
advertising they want to set the
customer up to get ready to buy oh yeah
oh yeah I saw that key I ad
by a Kia I want to buy some land and I
want to buy you this so the customer is
now primed to buy it that's marking his
job then the last thing is a sale so if
you've done a really good job on PR then
you've done a great job on marketing the
sale is like that you know they walk in
they buy but if you have no PR and you
have no marketing you have to pound
pound hard clothes a lot mr. customer
you know you know today's changing
business environment you know you should
buy my insurance and all and people
today hate sales pitches more than ever
before so the number one sales job of a
true entrepreneur is develop your
ability to get PR I'll say it again most
entrepreneurs are not good at sales
they're horrible at mark and have no
idea what it is and they can't get any
PR and so they struggle and again sales
equals income with a crush this is a
huge mistake that people make in
marketing that so many newsletters are
me what am I thinking
who did it to get lucky look at me hey
I'm an event hey buy me and whenever we
sit and write the newsletter we're
thinking about what is the most valuable
thing because somebody has actually
invited us into their inbox and that is
a critical question in marketing that
most people are not asking themselves or
spamming people and they're doing only
shits about them and they're not
thinking about why does somebody
subscribe to me and when we write that
newsletter that's why it is so
incredibly successful and why people
love it we're always thinking about does
this interest or help or entertain the
person that's reading it and you know
anytime that it turns out to be too much
of us talking about us somebody on the
team catches it thank God because
there's nothing more annoying than
having somebody go on and on
on about all that cool they're doing
versus thinking about what are some
interesting hacks and and and links and
cool things that we can introduce people
to that might improve their work or
their life when I started a Twitter
account I had no followers when I
started Facebook account no followers I
was my first follower when I started an
Instagram account no followers I didn't
know how to post video I didn't know how
to take a selfie I didn't know how to do
any of this but I did have a commitment
to grow in my finances and if you want
to grow your finances attention is the
gateway you want to go to heaven who
wants to go to heaven you got to die
just telling you man you got to die to
go to the heaven and most people don't
want to die they want to go to heaven
but they don't want to die most people
want money but they're not willing to
get the attention they're not willing to
do what it takes to get the attention
including spending money and I would
just tell you this if you want to change
your financial condition the first thing
you need to do is go out and market in
the marketplace so that you can create a
lead and not worry about whether there's
ROI or not it's so stupid that people
like what's the ROI do what's the ROI if
nobody knows you okay
what's the ROI if I don't know your name
don't know your company don't know what
you do don't know your service don't
know your product don't know where
you're located what is the ROI okay
best product does not win today the best
known product wins so if you're taking
notes write this down best known product
wins it always has won best car doesn't
win the best automobile doesn't win hey
what happened to the Volvo because it's
a Volvo you know safe in full control of
its power Oh is the safest car
the safest car that nobody has right but
it's the safest you think starbucks
sells the best coffee please nasty okay
but it's closed and I know what I'm
getting when I get there McDonald's say
let's sell the best hamburger
close and available when I started my
business I'd get money and I'd save it
I'd get money not say about get money
and I'd save it and I didn't spend money
in marketing and branding so when I was
writing the 10x rule I'm like dude why
am I not bigger than I'm I've been
busting my ass working so hard I've been
pushing and shoving I have the best
products of any anybody in my space I
know I have the biggest the biggest
platform of products in the best
problems why Wyatt why are other guys
kicking my ass and I'm like dude you you
haven't reinvested the money and
marketing and branding right I was not
spending money I look at the mattress
guy in Boston I look at the car dealer
in Boston Herb Chambers outspeed
everybody crushes the the mattress guy
out spins everybody the might the my
pillow guy on TV he who knows what he
spends he might spend a hundred million
dollars a year in advertising to get a
billion I'm like oh my god dumb-dumb
mm-hmm you didn't mark it and you didn't
have attached so this month we'll spend
probably a million dollars on
advertising on advertising if you're a
national bank instead of spending 50
million dollars on television
commercials and nobody sees I'd rather
go give a big-time production company
ten million dollars to be the sponsor of
a new show on Netflix called ATM where
the whole show transpires around ATMs
and it is literally your comeback like
actually not a made-up bank the Ed
Sullivan Show was funded and created by
the lincoln town car company
people forget that history television
started with brands funding it
commercials came later I believe now
that commercials are going to be
disappearing because we're watching
screaming I do not I do believe that
Netflix and Hulu and Amazon will test
commercials my intuition is if they're
smart they're gonna do product
integration and I think look let me give
you another one I've always thought that
a like a big car company with like the
trucks should do a show called the
tailgate or the whole show again is that
a tailgate and it's your truck is the
family's truck Toyota Ford and like that
works was held Egyptian kids watch to
the Masters yesterday I'm assured the
whole brand placement and lack of
advertising becomes it's just it's
amazing what can be done or the new
world we live in on Twitter the number
one thing that people were talking about
was Tiger chewing gum
and so we have a gum client so I called
him this is Sunday now you gotta move
fast
like hey dude did you you know like you
know like like there's moat like that I
don't if you guys saw it one of the
awards show the Fiji water girl right
the woman about it I think they call it
you know like that like that's moral wit
like guys nobody watches commercials
nobody goes through the direct mail
carefully nobody's going to page 37 of a
magazine looking at the ad carefully
like the world has changed I'm sorry
farming used to be our number one
industry things happen like Sears was
number one Walter Cronkite was you know
America's dad like things change I'm
sorry things changed things have changed
how do you apply that to business so
what you've learned in boxing the
blessings being a champion how that's
interesting because you know in business
as in boxing you know how to market
yourself you have to know what's gonna
allow people to bring with the Phillip
deceits
yeah and mine from my situation came
about I was the killer
I was the cycle tough guy about the
antihero and I'm the good guy was in the
bag
just you know I mean what I was a danger
this is a dangerous sport boxing and
about making much money you can in
taking the lesser risk as possible yeah
well what do you feel yourself I didn't
it's man all the way yeah I know all the
way never think about I'm the champ of
the world I never think about that stuff
because you can't only be able to move
forward how do you think that sports and
business can be similar or what's in
business art yeah same it's it's to
weight sports like me right yeah I'm
gonna show now I'm in the business
yeah it's a nice show business well it
was just a show now that story yeah
the box-office success when the
Shawshank Redemption came out with Dumb
and Dumber I'm just not gonna laugh Wow
no but that you know just the
juxtaposition of box office and and
what's that other term critical shopping
got really good reviews but because
nobody could say Shawshank Redemption
it didn't get word of mouth and I don't
care how much you promote a film if you
don't have word of mouth you may
promoting it people have to be able now
in to go and say listen I saw this
really terrific film it was called
[Music]
thank Sam
[Music]
Shimshon got on the elevator in LA one
day and the lady said oh I just saw you
in the hudsucker reduction
so that was the reason it was not a
box-office success
no word-of-mouth at all that was a dead
broke Carpet Cleaner living off credit
cards working hard struggling doing a
good job operating with integrity really
cared but there's no relationship
between being good and getting paid and
so until you actually learn how to sell
what it is that you're off whatever it
is service business internet business
you know being an author speaker doctor
doesn't matter you're in the the
marketing business and in the marketing
business you're in really the
relationship business yeah you know how
you can either be a transaction you know
marketer you can be a relationship
marketer and there's always as you know
there's always more money in in
relationships and I grew up incredibly
shy incredibly introverted so I'm kind
of like a introvert that learned how to
talk to people because if you don't
nothing happening is the most important
thing just like hold your breath for
three minutes and see how well you do
hold it for 5 minutes hold it for 10
minute you mean can't you'll die
marketing is like that for business if
people's businesses are struggling if
their missions and this is not just
business entrepreneur this is every heir
of your life I mean you know if you if
you have a partner you did some sort of
marketing there's something you did to
meet the person position yourself so to
answer the question
selling is what you do when you're on
the phone or face to face with somebody
marketing is what you do to get someone
on the phone or face to face with you so
that they're properly positioned so the
key the word positioning is really
critical so by the time that they
actually talk with you or visit your
store or go to your website or see you
speak their pre interested pre motivated
pre-qualified and predisposed to do
business with you and I've said that a
million times and I drilled that into my
head it's all about you know pre
interested pre motivated pre-qualified
predisposed and if people if people are
set up that way the whole job of selling
that selling is much easier frankly if
you have to rely on talking someone into
something then you just aren't doing any
marketing if you don't have enough
business you probably have plenty of
time so spend that time learning I mean
every one of us you included I mean we
have had to learn this this knowledge of
how to do webinars or how to do
videos or how to do podcasts or how to
write courses right ebooks and sales
letters and run events and you know
whatever we weren't just born with the
knowledge like anything else you have to
learn it so there's three ways that you
can learn you can learn through the
school of hard knocks and get yourself a
bolide even beaten up you can learn
through the experiences of other people
you read their books you go to their
seminars you invest in their courses and
the most effective way to learn is you
actually teach it to other people so
once you learn something like my buddy
eben pagan says speed of implementation
as soon as you hear an idea that the
quicker you can put it into practice the
more likely it's going to become
ingrained and it's going to come part of
your behavior and so this is a
behavioral change it's not just having
knowledge there are certain like a
strategy or a business plan or business
is a series of two do's done in a
certain order that produce a certain
result everything in life is a strategy
if your life is working there are
certain things you do in a certain way
that make it work if your life isn't
working there are certain things you're
doing that are making it not work so as
it comes to marketing the first thing to
understand is that the distinction
between selling and marketing if you
think marketing is like just a brand or
a logo I would encourage you to think
differently of less about the the way
your company looks and more about the
substance of what you're doing for the
client what is the value that you're
actually delivering even if you're
selling something that isn't
life-changing you know you're like a
comedy club you know how do you tell the
story about the comedy club so the
number one thing that I say to people if
you if you think of it this way if you
have something to sell write a sales
letter because a great sales person is
limited by the clock you can only talk
to so many people in a given day where
the first guy learned marketing from was
a guy named Gary Halbert who became a
dear friend of mine he passed away you
know about a decade ago but just a
brilliant copywriter and what I learned
with copy is copier the words words or
what sell and your ability to can and
clone yourself so sit down and write a
sales letter if you do not have a
written sales letter I mean handwriting
it's not about technology even Steve
Jobs said in 1997 that the Worldwide
Developers Conference he said we first
start with the psychology
not the technology and that's why Apple
did so well because he really thought
about the customer experience not about
the tech and so many tech companies that
swear up and down they had better stuff
than Apple it was just packaged in a way
it sits elegantly packaged and if you
look at all of Steve Jobs keynotes in
the Apple stores in the genius bars it
was all about education based marketing
so my first thing that I used in my
carpet cleaning business I'll give you
an example everyone in that industry
we're still the largest training
organization in the world from cleaners
and restores I don't run much of it
anymore but I have someone that does I
still own it we have thousands of carpet
and upholstery cleaners all over the
world now people would be like one
that's not my business how does that
apply to me if you have to figure out
how to successfully sell something
nobody wants to buy it forces you to
learn a lot about marketing so I had
like how do you position something that
nobody even really wants to do it's like
they have carpet and it got dirty or a
cat pissed on it or whatever now I have
to deal with it it's it's an the
necessary evil of owning the stuff no no
one likes it but I had to learn how to
sell other than price so one of the
first things I did was education based
marketing and I learned one of the most
effective ways to sell something is to
simply educate people on how to make a
buying decision because the number one
question in all consumers Minds is who
can I trust and so your job as a
business owner your job as a marketer is
to establish trust and rapport there's
sharing that can be done through social
media when you actually hit a share or
retweet but there's also which I think
is a little more familiar to this world
the word of mouth effect and I have
gotten to achieve that as well so the
kids go to school and they talk about
what happened in the vlog the day before
versus just sharing a funny video it's
like it's become a Passat ik these kids
I watch me 15 minutes a day they're a
part of my life and so they want to tell
their friends about it when I do the
crazy things like filling a first class
bathroom with my clothing line the kids
go to school they talk about and then it
gets occasionally typical mainstream
media presses word of mouth word of
mouth best marketing ever best
ever anyhow that's crazy is until about
six months ago I didn't realize that
because I'm a social media guy and then
when it became like oh snap this is like
people are talking in real life about
this that's when I think the celebrity
effect sort of happens to me marketing
is about values this is a very
complicated world it's a very noisy
world and we're not going to get a
chance to get people to remember much
about us no company is and so we have to
be really clear on what we want them to
know about us now Apple fortunately is
one of the half-a-dozen best brands in
the whole world right up there with Nike
Disney Coke Sony it is one of the greats
of the greats not just in this country
but all around the globe and but but but
even a great brand needs investment and
caring if it's going to retain its
relevance and vitality and the Apple
brand has clearly suffered from neglect
in this area in the last few years and
we need to bring it back the way to do
that is not to talk about the speeds and
fees it's not to talk about nips and
magazines it's not to talk about why
you're better than windows the dairy
industry tried for 20 years to convince
you that milk was good for you the lie
but they tried anyway and the sales were
going like this and then they tried got
milk and the sales are going like this
God not the thing to talk about
apartment that focus is on the absence
of the product
what but but the best example of all and
and one of the greatest jobs of
marketing and though if the universe has
ever seen is Nike remember Nike sells a
commodity they sell shoes and yet when
you think of Nike you feel something
different than a shoe company and their
ads as you know they don't ever talk
about the products they don't ever tell
you about their soils and weather better
than Reebok their souls
where's Nike doing their advertising
they they honor great athletes and they
honor great athletics that's who they
are
that's what they are about I will spend
a fortune on advertising you'd never
know it you never know so when I got
here you Apple just fired their agency
we're doing a competition with 23
agencies that you know four years from
now with pick one and we blew that up
and we hired Shaddai the ad agency that
I was fortunate enough to work with
years ago we created some award-winning
work including the commercial voted the
best dad ever made 1984 by advertising
professionals and we started working
about eight weeks ago and what was the
question they asked was our customers
want to know who is Apple and what is it
that we stand for where do we fit in
this world and
what we're about isn't making boxes for
people to get their job done although we
do that well we do that better than
almost anybody in some cases but apples
about something more than that
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people if passion can
change the world for the better that's
what we believe and we've had the
opportunity to work with people like
that we've had an opportunity work with
people like you with software developers
with customers who have done it in some
big in some small way and we believe
that in this world people can change it
for the better and that those people
that are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are the ones that
actually do and so what we're going to
do in our first brand marketing campaign
in several years is to is to get back to
that core value a lot of things have
changed the markets a totally different
place than it was a decade ago and
apples totally different in Apple's
place in it it's totally different and
believe me the products and the
distribution strategy in manufacturing
are totally different and we understand
that the values and core values those
things shouldn't change the things that
Apple believed in at its core are the
same things that Apple really stands for
today
and so we wanted to find a way to
communicate this and what we have is
something that I am I'm very moved by it
honors those people who have changed the
world some of them are living some of
them are not
but the ones that aren't as you'll see
you know but if they ever use the
computer it would have been a Mac the
theme of the campaign is think different
it's the people honoring the people who
think different and who move this work
forward and it's it is what we are about
it touches the soil of this company so I
mean go ahead and roll it and I hope
that you feel the same way about it I do
[Music]
years to the crazy ones
The Misfits rebels the troublemakers the
round pegs in the square holes
once you see things
and they have no respect
you can quote them disagree with them
glorify or vilify them not the only
thing you can't do
a change
and while some may see them as the crazy
ones
because the people who are crazy enough
to think they can change the world
do
now I've got a special bonus cup that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best live 30 questions
of the day
it's not enough to just watch a video
you have to do something about it so
pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below here we go
question number one what's your core
value that you are going to mark it
around number two where do you need to
invest more in your marketing and number
three how will you generate
word-of-mouth for your business and if
you're doing the best live 30 challenge
with me put a hashtag best live 30 in
the comments below
we want to celebrate you you have to pay
to play okay we tell it to clients but
sometimes we don't want to do it
ourselves what does that even pay the
play what it means is if you want to be
seen by people you have to pay someone
to do so
alright if we're getting back to the old
days there was radio there was
television people paid money to show it
yeah and the internet comment came along
and we thought okay well we can create a
viral video we can blog or we can do all
this free stuff and people will just
find us okay if a truthfully if you want
to save time if you want to find the
right people and you want them targeted
you have to lean on Google AdWords right
which is pay-per-click where you can
have the different ads that you want and
based on different search terms yeah
people come in and they find you you can
go to Facebook right we're creative
people we can design banners we design
videos we can boost posts yeah go to
Facebook around who we want to target
what they're interested in yeah and we
drive traffic to the site yeah we don't
you know at this point with our clients
I can't recall the last time we ran any
kind of activity without the expectation
that there would be some advertising
budget got it that people would put
$1,000 a month or $800 a month or $5,000
a month whatever it might be they would
put money towards finding people who are
looking for their service and dropping
them there right is it the fastest way
to grow right now the faster I get
awareness yeah fastest way it always has
been all right so we we it's most
expensive way but it's the fastest way
well it's expensive if you're not
tracking anything so that was that was
gonna be our third point yeah we'll just
move it up to number two okay number two
right you gotta track you have to track
yeah like it's it's mind-boggling to me
that people put money towards things
without
yeah and so you know maybe like Google
Analytics is pretty confusing I find it
confusing I have someone who can help me
yeah but but at the very least you need
to be able to track your goals so set a
goal do we want awareness yeah do want
people just to see it you want
conversion to know people to actually
click through and come through do we got
a conversion on sale there are there's
software for call tracking so if you
have a phone number you can you know we
pay a service and it's $35 a month it
goes to all our numbers so we know if
this person came in through Google and
called us we can attribute that lead to
that call mm-hmm
all right there are all these different
things available they're not really that
expensive they're not really that
complicated but it's all with the
intention of being able to get to a
place where I can say I spent eight
hundred dollars and I closed a ten
thousand dollar deal mm-hmm right or I
spent two thousand dollars and I closed
a hundred thousand dollar deal yeah I
mean there's a lot of wasted bad leads
in there and it's like eight dollars
here and ten dollars there and all this
stuff but and the client comes along
that the client you want you win that
client you keep them for five years that
client refers you to other people and
you're over a year you know it's it
grows your business but people one are
not willing to spend money on it and
they should and then people too are not
tracking as much as they can and they're
just wasting money on stuff if you want
to join the best life 30 challenge click
the link right here below me or if you
want more videos on how to be a better
marketer check out the playlist right
there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon